une minute de silence et un discours
pour le conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce jeudi 26
septembre
des mots prononcés par le président qui
a côtoyé l'ancien chef de l'état jean
michel fourgous a travaillé deux ans
avec lui à la sortie de sciences po
c'est un homme généreux et a nommé
général tout le monde pas uniquement à
qu'à droite ou la gauche il et il a
quelque chose et il a il avait un je
dirais une force de travail hors norme
une mémoire assez impressionnante qui
m'a toujours impressionné il avait le
sens de l'humour il avait il était
bienveillant avec la il aimait la france
engagé en politique pendant plus de 40
ans jacques chirac a inspiré de nombreux
politiques saint quentinois notamment
chez les plus jeunes
un grand homme d'état qui me quitte
aujourd'hui avec qui j'ai grandi
ce que j'ai 37 ans et mon premier vote
je m'en souviens c'est en 2000 pour le
référendum sur le quinquennat et ensuite
voilà j'ai voté pour lui en 2002 c'est
aussi à toute ma construction politique
puisque j'avais adhéré à l'ump à
l'époque quand c'était la grande famille
de la droite et du centre
en tant que jeune élu c'est vrai que
c'est forcément un personnage qui m'a
marqué qui m'a marqué par l'humanité qui
le mettait dans tout ce qu'il faisait et
que tout le monde a ressenti comme l
amour est d'abord tous ses concitoyens
pour son pays et puis aussi son combat
contre les extrêmes
un hommage populaire à l'ancien chef
d'état est organisé dimanche 29
septembre à paris à un moment de
recueillement a été demandée par
matignon lundi 30 septembre à 15h dans
les mairies